wofür sind sie recht die ganze denn die
hirnrinde von den ursachen finden aber
es muss auch mal sein muss so ich finde
auch ganz viele rails immer in chains
and book das habe ich ihnen die textur
drin weiß 14.7 ist ich habe eine
standhafte drohnen also sondern eine
biene oder sogar angst ich hab so eine
biene gefunden schlagerstar endlich hats
doch gelernt
also nimmt seinen kino also keine ahnung
ist es bringt nicht einfach mit viel
reisen mit enchanted book wir sind immer
so ein chart potsdamer nicht ein
gut ich gebe weiter es braucht kein
mensch
ich wäre euch und diamanten im grunde
jede würde gegangen ja ich glaube es
gibt so viel dass man auch wie viel
weniger relevant findet hier kein
schwert mir oh mein gott nein ich habe
zwei schwerter funktionieren wie sein ex
klub explodiert und hatte in einer
erklärung zu den tod gerissen
die arme wenn ich beim crafting table
yahoo gold gold ja gold ich wollte immer
schon gold haben du hast gold gold gold
gold gold gold gold gold gold gold gold
das ist noch ein repeater läuft auf mich
zu
der zombie ist tot er ist toto lotto
jackpot ist so viel holz nicht so
wichtig damit die politik zum tiebreak
ich brauche keine zum libretto für
breiter schon wer bin ich bist du mit
rudi assauer braucht die pasta machen
lassen diamant nein wahrscheinlich lieb
ist oder so halten dass er seine
doppelspurigen dings jetzt hier doppel
schulgemeinschaft links und fuhr ohne
licht aus diamant ich sehe gar nicht so
bewusst hier lang geht dann kommt ihr
doch wasserratten sie waren auch
creepers ich hab hier in whistler
anzugehen wir das voller wasser ist und
es nervt mich ein bisschen
ganz ganz viele wales mit ich habe doch
keine regel von wo ist ihr ganzes land
ich habe eine top picks fertig doch
jetzt erst mal ausprobieren schüler
sonst rombey das ist bitter traurig so
was geht da ab
ja ich schau mal was kann ich denn hier
einlassen pflastersteine pro jetzt noch
nicht tommy and pics für das kern der
königskinder nämlich mit das kind gut
und le matin kommentar geschrieben das
wir außennetz auch etwas holen für die
energie also für dieses eu das was am
meisten bringt sehr gute pigs finde ich
sehr gut
ich freue mich irgendwie ne dass das
macht spaß man hat einfach so viele neue
sachen ja ich bin auch robbie williams
wird immer mehr verschiedene sachen ja
und vor allem an werden weiß auch
langsam zum beispiel tauben dass das so
gut wie einig wir bringen uns auch
selber schon so ein bisschen bei das
wundert mich so ein bisschen dass wir
das auch hinkriegen
ich habe das gefühl - oder besser ich
habe auch das gefühl dass tomlin besser
ist du bist doch nur nach räder dreht
alles klar
ich habe vorher gesagt la paloma vor der
gefunden
egal denkt ihr alles von geklaut haben
ein schacht gefunden der die du auch
schon ja ich bin auf und die konzerten
anderen schüler seine kiste gefunden
wissenschaftler über platz wenn die
amber gold enchanted book für den job
des book das kann ich dir drin lassen
mili um scherbe ich als ich minimum
scherbe fehlt den kerlen was ist mit tim
kaine was machen das hier ganz viel
liegen lassen
gleichzeitig lässt alles liegen weil ich
hab so was von viele sachen es ist
richtig und was kann man sich mitnehmen
sondern was nicht ich habe so viel
einschaltete bücher auch
die aber noch gar keine textur haben
weil wegen kann man sich nicht in sein
inventar vergrößern wenn man sich so ein
rucksack aufsetzen oder so gibst du was
ich auch schreibt was bitte in die
kommentare
das wäre cool das werde ich
ich brauche schon so immer ab und
realisiere danach dann immer so gar kein
platz dafür bin ich würde sagen hey ist
doch gar nicht als abbauen sondern wenn
wir dann eben anders mehr hingehen aber
ich glaube hier war es noch nicht wo ich
hier bislang gehe also der hier genau
hier direkt an dieser stelle ich bin
seinen diesen mini schacht wieder
erstaunlich aber hier sieht rennen
gleich ein
ich glaube schon ja der ist auch riesig
groß heftig sollten sie also einen weg
den plätzen und dann uns hier sind ohne
dahin
ich habe ich alle bauern punkte gesetz
zu den ganzen kisten und so ich werde
jetzt noch nicht alle kisten mitnehmen
sondern dann erst noch mal wiederkommen
level 36 jetzt schon geil
es gibt erst jetzt wo der franzose hey
guck mich so wie das bonner gefunden ist
schon für friedel schmidt am hopstener
gefunden schaukästen drin ist es sind
sie ja selbst links drin und einen
tauben dem schwert hypotheken poker
poker poker poker poker weiter
ich hab mich so darauf gefreut endlich
was mit der portugal machen so gar
nichts mit allerdings gefunden bohrer
alter brauch ich bin dazu froh kramer
ich habe so viele sachen ich das geld
was ich jetzt hier lassen sollte ich
dass die werkbank sollte schaut euch das
an
richie porte dann so in der kiste ins
geschäft oder schaut euch das an der
wiese ich traue mich dadurch zu gehen
ist es so schwarz ich mache das
vielleicht mit dem testweise aber borst
das geld schaut euch das anders ich
freue mich so ich liebe das ihr hobby
die politik den rest an nikolic ist auch
schon die politik ja doch sein sieg oder
setzlinge kann ich auch wir verstecken
beiser setzt nämlich auch schon baldus
setzlinge und noch in chats bock so ich
mache das jetzt einfach mal so was ist
denn noch so blöd richtig kohle dem ich
nicht ich kohle dann könnte ich
vielleicht noch ein bisschen was ist
eigentlich drin was ich denken kann 13
flaschen wodka nicht rechtlich
wertvolles dings dietary flaschen im
jahr mit dino lecce fragmente ist es das
wert sagt mir ist es wert den bogen der
bogen der ist auch schon volker putze
ich will da noch gerne das mädchen ist
deutlich überlegt wertvoller als am
boden
kohle käme mitnehmen na gut ich habe auf
jeden fall schonmal ne portal gun geil
die musst du erstmal zeigen uns dass
langsam auf dem weg zur schon auf dem
weg zu ihr zurück du bist du bist auf
den weg nach hause
ich bin auch eine kiste du bist ein weg
zur kiste oben oder wo ist auch weg ich
bin auf dem weg zur höhlen kiste 2 und
dann nehme ich die sachen nee ich gehe
zum höchster 1 oder ich gehe erst mal zu
erhöhen ist in zwei lager in sachen drin
dann gehe ich zu erhöhen setzte 1
und nimmt man die sache und lager die
wiederum eine hohe gäste 2 und so weiter
und dann nehme ich die sachen immer
aushöhlen gäste zwei dann mit in die
kiste zu mir nach hause alt die lava sie
zu krass mpo ich hab so einen riesigen
und helfen da was sie gefunden und ist
aber was für ein lama see hallo mo
unbedingt diamanten halter für diese
bescheuerten den schaden in table
es ist mir die ganzen levels gar nichts
ich muss irgendwas sein bei diesem lager
sei dass das riecht mir aber nach einer
da muss mal reingehen also bevor ich
hier raus gehe ich bin auf dem weg zu
einer höheren kaste 20 meter von ihr
entfernt
indirekt über ihre us 1 ab die schon mal
so ein dass sie gesehen was da los war
stand osterlohs donnerstag
ich hab so was von viele sachen da ist
richtig geil sagt erstmal die kiste
vergrößern
holz brauche ich denn dafür acht braucht
man die kiste 233 casting der wand
gefahren das finde ich schon bisschen
bisschen schade schade schade schade
ja ich meine wir waren ja auch mal
nutzer auf etwas höheren höhen so
schnell darauf für zwölf also ich wäre
jetzt perfekt für diamanten selbst
jemanden natürlich perfekt aber ich
glaube hellblau türkis habe ich ja ich
glaube dass wir die qualität
schon wieder dieses nicoletta daraus ich
habe meine workbench stellten wir lassen
ja toll dann brauche ich jetzt auf jeden
fall
asko holz soll jeder drei holzhütten die
nur von a nach b am laufen und somit
immer nur holz ich habe acht gut ich
begebe mich dann zu langsam gleitet auf
den rückweg nicht reden doch ich komme
mit ja und dann doch ziemlich klar
aufgenommen treffen uns auf die kiste 1
darüber will das fest einst war er lange
langen expedition muss mir die sachen
und holte dann halte ich die sachen von
hier wiederum hinweise zu mir nach hause
demnächst bevor wir das nächste mal
spielen erkundige ich mich ganz genau
was man als mit den ganzen ersten machen
kann und dann auch werden wir das sehr
sinnvolles daraus kreieren sowie
portugal lasse ich auch hoffentlich
niemand will sie lässt du hier
nein ich lasse dich in der kiste 2
das machst du nicht dass meine diamant
alles drin sagt schill ich will dass du
alles rum wissen direkt ausprobieren so
schnell wie es geht oder ja aber
trotzdem ich die ganzen sachen erst mal
überholen soll ich frage mich gerade für
meine zweite habe ich denn nur in
anderen höhlen kiste da ich sie deinen
namen in der ganz weite ferne
in welche richtung
ja gar nicht sagen ich hoffe zu denen
kannst du mich zu der an unsere alten
höhen führen